the one that stands out to me of people
getting too drunk was we we met these
girls on the street at the store yeah we
started talking to them they're like big
fans and they want to [ __ ] and this is
back in the day before though they just
came up in proposition she wasn't there
Tim so I get on FaceTime I'm like yo
these girls are cute and they want to
[ __ ] and uh she comes through we're on
the podcast and as soon as they said
they wanted to hang out like that I
[ __ ] send one of the employees to the
store to buy a bottle of Hennessy within
maybe 10 minutes of the podcast starting
one of them was in the bathroom puking
her [ __ ] face off and then the other
ones tried to abandon her and leave her
with us and I was like babysitting I
don't want her here anymore you have to
take her away and so that was a real
learning experience about alcohol on the
podcast and did you guys kill those
girls or what
assist from [ __ ] Tristan Thompson
because they're talking about banging
him while he was married so what's her
name Kardashian yeah wait he's cheated
really he sends cease and desistence his
legal team got in touch yeah [ __ ] a
who's the biggest cornball that you've
experienced in Hollywood
I don't want you to actually get in
trouble you don't have to say anything
but I'm just like I imagine you're
interacting with these people and you
have a certain like um you have a level
of like connection but you don't rely on
them for anything so you can actually be
real with them right and then you get to
see if someone's corny or not um
is anybody like really let you down
anybody in the industry like is there
anybody that you were really excited to
meet and you're like oh [ __ ] this is all
fabrication for sure personality combing
the inside of my brain trying to think
of somebody I could name that I wouldn't
get I don't want to get you into a
situation yeah it felt like a leading
question I don't want you but I am
curious because there are very few
people that are in Los Angeles that are
not directly plugged into Hollywood but
I interview almost nobody who's tapped
into that world like I don't even I
don't know there's some musicians I
think sometimes but most of the
musicians I interview are really like
not on that type of time like a lot of
our biggest like my biggest interview
this year I got three million views from
interviewing this dude 1090 Jake it was
a white blood from Massachusetts that's
another thing I text you about yeah I'm
like I'm just watching white gang
members
the 1090 Jake the milk gang okay guy
yeah Pino right I'm seeing them all beef
with each other and I'm watching their
[ __ ] it's unbelievable 1090 jigs just
for the people at home and shout out to
Pinot because I think he's a good guy
but he uh basically he was able to go
into the legal system and spend money to
obtain a copy of a 13 year old in
interrogation that this dude Pino had
done where he got arrested for somebody
was stealing something and he's
basically snitching in the video he's
like Talent on some girl that was
involved with it or whatever and uh 1098
got a 13 year old video of him in the
back of a police station doing this
interview and made a YouTube video about
it which right that really tells you a
lot about what's going on this YouTube
world because I mean if you were to get
pulled into a police station and they
were talking to you about something
tomorrow are you even thinking that
there's a chance that that video becomes
public Adam I'm snitching right let me
just tell you but 13 years later like
that just really blew my mind the the
level of this [ __ ] has really
changed yeah I mean there's money there
yeah when there's money there people are
going to keep making the videos yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]